[Música]
soy
así un 29 enero de 1984
tuve la suerte y el privilegio de hacer
postres y mucha diversión
cuando tres años nos fuimos seguir a
trujillo al papa levantarse por trabajo
entonces cuatro mi papá mi mamá mi
hermana no fuimos allá el momento yo era
una niña normal pero siempre me ocuparé
con mi amigo porque porque yo era la
línea complicada y era el aplicada como
esos términos los pocos yo nunca le
pusieron mis papás
jugaba con mis compañeros pero cuantos
más como era el de niña dice que siempre
ser una lucha vigilada bajo la viña está
cuando había que bailar me ponía a
llorar y no porque me costaba mucho
estas situaciones en donde yo entré la
atención
como el día de hoy
pasó el tiempo y me di cuenta que yo
aprendía diferente
lo que decía el profesor era lo mismo
que yo escuchaba porque veía que quizá
me entendían entonces llegó el momento
de evaluar cuando el niño o las cuatro
me cabreé isasti massa también te vas
aprendiendo de forma muy lúdica pero
cuando vas creciendo ese aprendizaje
cambia porque a veces al multiplicar
y ahora tiene que saber a pares no
recito de plastilina si contiene es que
existe
si no tienes que saber sumar
a los pretéritos y todo eso es muchísimo
trabajo
sancho y que no y el inteligente
pasó el tiempo aproximadamente 10 años y
me acuerdo que me sentía muy segura de
mí misma y fue cometido una etapa un
poco complicada es lo que sufría mucho
muñeco y anima y nos hace duras de
repente por alguna provincia por ayuda
de lilita por usar lentes o simplemente
por aprender
igual que cualquier persona que sufrió
bullying
clarísima y sé que actúa en base a sus
propias inseguridades
y todo esto que yo siga siendo una
persona muy muy segura que no era capaz
de mí mismo
porque sabía reflejada todas libretas
gustación los días le pido a mis papás
los recortes de mi libreta porque quería
acordarme
a ver si curioso las acordadas una
partecita o si realmente era como me
imaginaba que efectivamente toda la
militancia puede rendir más puede sentir
más puede rendir más y no saben o no
registradas les pondría problemas lo que
nadie explicaba como que también es
quitada como yo estaba aprendiendo
diferente y exponencial de ruta
simplemente le hacía diferente y eso es
algo que ahora 75 años puede quitar
pero en esa época una libreta con vasos
notas es un sinónimo de niño soy
inteligente ahora es diferente
simplemente este tipo de estudio para mí
era diferente
postulé a otra universidad en donde para
la sorpresa de todos entre muy buen
puesto
el primer ciclo me fue muy bien para
sorpresa de todos que sorpresa para mí
sobre todo
pero nunca me sentí como mis compañeros
pasó el tiempo extra que ocultar y
lamentablemente decisoria reflejaba mis
compañeros en la clase derecho todos
hablan de los mismos me acuerdo que
salíamos de repente a tomar una cerveza
y seguían hablando de ciencia como
quieren hablar de algo de lo que yo
solamente en él quiero olvidar los
profesores solamente se acordaban de que
no solamente porque bailada clases o
porque jalaba porque siempre tienen
extremadura al final de las clases que
quiero estar contigo
la misma historia se repetía del colegio
a la universidad
entonces ahí se me ocurrió la brillante
idea
decido porque voy a decir aquí el tiempo
que puedes dar pero yo creo que tengo
que ser una madre de familia
y lo digo en esa época porque ahora se
lo familiar
como debería ser
a las familias para que vengan un chico
con este cáncer y ya esto de estudiarse
en una profesional exitosa ya no tengo
que lidiar con eso entonces vinieron los
primeros enamorados que vamos a
encontrar con esta chica súper tibia
insegura de mi cuerpo de discapacidad y
absolutamente todo chicos muy buenos y
luego llegó la relación no se rompería
feliz y nunca había estado tan destruida
por dentro una relación que expreso
siendo maravillosa con esta feliz
absurdo que tenía de lo que era tener un
noveno marcado
poco a poco esta relación se convirtió
en la relación más tóxica que he tenido
y decidió cualquier práctica autoestima
que yo muerte
afectó la relación que tiene la
universidad con mis amigos con mis papás
y en esa chica amargada que en su
cultura
lamentablemente es una época complicada
para mí incluso hay momentos que no me
acuerdo debido a decisiones muy malas
que me dicen en ese momento pero después
de mucho tratamiento y mucha medicación
y sobre todo no sé cómo aguantar tanto
tiempo detener a esta hija pude salir de
eso y no voy a salir en estos fondos de
trabajo porque me costó montón de
trabajo conocerme y saber de lo que era
valioso y ahora pasaba por tres carreras
y estaba pero está en la segunda carrera
está diseñando psicología
porque estábamos responsabilidad y así
fueron todos los días cada vez
pero
6 pero lo que más profesores
quiero identificar mucho con ellos
porque yo abre el día de la misma manera
yo le llene un libro sino jugando de
forma muy lúdica y por eso creo que me
gustó mucho ser profesora y ahí es donde
llegaba la reunión de fin de mes y nos
contaban para el conocido nos había ido
a las profesoras y se referían al mixto
con la creativa paloma la creativa no
sólo para la creativa y eso es algo que
nunca escuchado pero gracias en algo que
nunca bienvenidos muchas
llegó el momento de tener un poco más de
ingresos como lamentablemente es el
profesor de primaria o de inicial en el
que mejor dicho practicante no tiene un
buen sueldo y si se compara con mis
amigos ellos ya estaban ganando
muchísimo más y ya me había casado ser
repente de mis papás que tuve la suerte
que las cosas durante todo este proceso
entonces se exhibirá este talento que no
era muy útil como preparar postres para
realizar la negocio online y así fue que
hizo un par de las cejas y haber par de
amigos que compraron esos amigos y poco
a poco este negocio fue creciendo sin
que yo me imaginé oficial que no había
dicho que yo hubiera estado y audio
estar acá para hablar de esto
eso era interno ese tenemos una mano
funcional por eso digo que ignorancia en
mi mayor fortaleza porque yo no tenía
idea que quiera tener un negocio los de
vida de cómo manejarlo de cómo ver la
parte de recursos humanos de cómo ver la
parte d
determinados emprendiendo el camino
empezando de cero y tuve que crecer a mi
manera a mis propios versos al saber un
poco de contabilidad del banco de
recursos humanos a saber cómo lidiar con
complicadas pero lo aprendí a mi manera
y cómo es que fue tuve que vivirlos para
poder aprenderlo porque yo aprendo ciclo
ley n sino vivido las cosas
y el día de hoy
me siento muy orgullosa porque a pesar
de todas estas dificultades para
identificar en diferentes hechos no me
hace menos manejo un equipo de 15
personas
tengo una de las tiendas más conocidas
del perú escrito dos libros y
diferencias a veces de emprendimiento y
decir que tengo éxito porque como ven en
esa seguridad audio de la noche en la
mañana y vivir en un país un poco
machista para una mujer emprendedores
complicadas porque no tenemos que estar
diciendo solamente una vez que estamos
donde estamos por esfuerzo sino que
estamos tenemos que repetirlo
constantemente
y sacar lo mejor de mí pero yo no soy
solo un negocio que funciona bien yo soy
mucho más y eso me gustó
y cuando ya me hice un poquito más a mí
misma yo de querer además y sabía y
siempre quería hacerlo de cosas
diferentes que voy un poco contra
corridos
y así para mi vida así que enseñarme que
los ritos no se acaban y estaba bien era
diferente porque es una forma sana es
una forma que saca lo mejor de mí
porque es una forma que me hace muy
feliz y que me ha ayudado a encontrarme
conmigo misma de verdad
y lo diga nuestras latinas y las cuatro
somos una familia poco convencional
probablemente y distinta a las demás
somos plenamente felices
y por eso estoy acá porque estoy segura
que la paloma chiquitina de la primera
foto le hubiera gustado escuchar una
historia como la mía
comprendiendo que los caminos
[Música]
[Aplausos]